my guest has been in the film industry
most of his life he has acted alongside
film giants like Steven Spielberg Robin
Williams Mickey Rooney and that's just
to name a few
he's voice actors some of your favorite
shows like Avatar The Last Airbender
american dragon jake long and has been
crazy enough to throw fire at me through
a Chicagoland Barnes & Noble please
welcome the very awesome Dante Bosco how
are you sir very good how are you doing
I'm doing great man doing great thank
you so much for being here thanks for
having uh I think it only figures to
talk about your most popular character
we all know you played in when you were
very young begins with an R ends in an O
let's get to it when you played Romeo in
Michael Jackson yeah uh everyone knew
you were gonna be a huge it was just
gonna be this huge part so memorable
that most people deliever remember the
name of that character but on IMDB even
though everyone just thought you were a
dancer you officially have a name in
Michael Jackson's Moonwalker and it's
from you tell us about how that part
just laid way for this incredible
awesome yeah no nothing nothing yeah I'm
Matthew just a dancer in that video I
don't know I'm more than a dance Aaron
you are Romeo it's just so much about
you
I don't know how IMDB works but certain
things get on there that I have no I
have to have the incorrectness but you
can never get them off either but it is
defined a generation despite you think
you were just a dancer I we all see you
as Romeo so thank you but it sort of
left a big impact on my life and many
others well I'm glad with that said um
you got to acting very very young I
start acting when you were what ten
years old I believe uh ten yes yeah did
it was it easy to sort of warm up to the
Hollywood scene cuz I mean you went
right into movies music videos and stuff
yeah adjustment before where I'm
originally from me and my family are
from the Bay Area little town outside of
San Francisco and we're break dancers
and 80s so before we got to LA we were
we were dancing so literally we're
dancing every weekend my mom did our
stats one time
before we got to LA we we 134 uh
breakdancing contest
oh they got picked up by the san
fracisco ballet company did the
Nutcracker we danced for way with
breakdancing Nutcracker oh no it was
actually they and the 80s they were
short on boys so they had to find uh
dancers to kind of to become ballet
dancer so I was really Billy Elliot that
film is like really emotional to me
because it's really realizing my life
story
if Billy Elliot was about break dancing
ballet that would be unbelievable right
so like they've got break dance from the
streets and they gave us scholarships to
learn ballet no kidding yeah so he did
that me my brothers did that and then we
danced we were dancers for the 49ers
for the Oakland A's uh for the USFL team
at the time the Oakland invaders and we
did all that before we got to LA when I
was the age of 10 so by the time we got
to LA Weaver II you know I had all that
kind of experience going on so so you
are used to working with something go
here do this do that
yeah let's - Lutz a yes sir I guess
we're like professional dancers before
we got to LA become professional actors
I don't know what made you want to
transfer into acting then from dancing
uh it seemed I mean we didn't know we
were going to it's like we came to LA as
dancers um but when you get to LA you
quickly realize like you know it's an
and it's an actor's world as far as act
it's a bit filmmaking it's movies and
television and so we briskly got into
acting I think our first dance agent was
like Lloyd wait you should go in
auditions for film and television and
commercials also okay and just saying
that my parents got us into my mother
guys to an acting class and and I think
I booked my first audition so it just
kind of went from that I roll from there
uh going off of the first question there
what is it like being the lost boy
everyone can agree on because everybody
loves Murphy yeah nobody dislikes Murphy
oh it's amazing
yeah Rufio I you know it's one of those
carrots actually I don't have word it's
like one of those weird things like
everyone comes to Hollywood to hopefully
do some kind of character sometime that
you'll be remembered for you know that
kind of thing and for a generation that
grew up in the 90s
one Rufio was there and it just was an
impactful character for a lot of people
so and for me too
I mean if I wasn't if I didn't play the
character I'd still be a fan of the
character because he's just cool you
know very cool kind of antihero gets
killed uh just kind of been you know I
just feel kind of fortunate to be that's
that's part of my resume something you
were talking about I never noticed uh is
that you were saying Rufio was very much
a child of the 80s and a lot of people I
create systems of that but you pointed
out that that was far Spielberg's plan
cuz all the kids were from different
time periods over time I saw from the
50s some from the 60s and so on so forth
um is so did they have mascara in
Neverland if you bring that from Ibiza
how does that work I have no idea you
know it's like the whole thing it's like
it's cool now like you look at Rufio
it's cool now but when when first book
the role there was no image for what
it's gonna be
I just so many sketches that they had
there was a sketching at me with
dreadlocks I mean there's a part of
bangarang isn't like a like a Jamaican
word so there was original idea for me
to be like very Jamaican ish you know
you play so many different cultures in
this w haven't actually done Jamaican
United dungeon making yet um but then
you know when we did that particular
outfit and Steven Spielberg was like yes
that's the look and when you're young
you're like this is really the look this
is it I'm wearing a Michael Jackson
jacket and and in a midriff shirt like
wow this is not how I'm gonna be in this
big movie uh now looking back you're
like it's cool and then of course yeah
the whole thing with a mascara when he's
going the fight scene like you know I'm
off it's the makeup or a Steven they're
like you know let's try this and you
know you're a kid on the set going that
is what we're gonna do I gotta wear this
weird makeup and then it becomes like
classic for the time so it's definite
that's a very iconic there's only one
Rufio yeah
only one look everybody got it he
apparently never changes his clothes I
don't know how he smells does his
clothes like he has to go up every
morning and do the moose in the hair so
which is crazy cuz every Halloween
was get pictures of cosplayers uh people
getting dressed up as Rufio and then
would Twitter now and tumblr
you know people write you that named
their animals Rufio and their sons Rufio
which is crazy Wow and it's cool you
like that's cool name I'm glad that you
named your child after uh my character
bait but become roof for sure roof be no
no roofie roofie give me a roofie come
on
and then he's not gonna get many dates
no and then I recently wrote a blog
actually like last week about how you
know you're part of pop culture is when
people start tattooing you on their body
core so here's a lot of rufio tattoos so
my 15 year old face adorns the body of
several uh guys and girls just you know
and it's kind of flattering it's like I
just want those things like how do you
feel about that it's like I don't I get
it I mean I get it it means something to
you it means something to the whole
generation so if people know who it is
they totally understand what you're
about you'd like a lost boy lost girl I
get it like bangerang
is very you know it's a whole thing so
it's just interesting when it's your 15
year old face on someone else's arm or
leg or back or something
Oh is there any truth that Steven
Spielberg is so nice as a director that
you immediately want to go punch someone
just to sort of offset it uh he is nice
but um he was very nice but he's also my
memory oh he's a very strong director
you know especially with kids he was
very uh he would get that moments he
wants to get somehow you know with me
and him he he would always his big it's
so ironic it's like so funny like he
would always stop me because I was
always yeah young actor and I guess I
was imitating my heroes right so Marlon
Brando one of them and you'd be like cut
your stop imitating Brando go back and
you know do it again which is hilarious
but he definitely as nice as he was as a
person and lovely he ought was also very
not hard on the actress because very
about getting the performance he wanted
to get especially from a lot of kid
actors so my memory was he's very strong
director well you have to be you I mean
just looking at that set yeah any of
those sets I mean it's huge and there's
so many people on there uh and yet I
hear he's always like you said so kind
with kids
yes actually so good with yeah yeah he's
just an ease kind of another generation
of directors and he does a certain thing
that not a lot of directors can do he's
an epic director epic you know it's like
doing hook of course all these epic sets
in all this an epic storyline but even
seeing warhorse the way he directed
certain moments and you're seeing a
grand director it's like not all
directors can be a be a conductor for a
symphony that big these means that of
course act very yeah well said his lines
and now the eyes look yeah it's like he
understands know this like a braver you
have to have to go and this is the shot
it's gonna be the super wide shot of a
field and a horse and let the force to
stand there I mean there's certain thing
that it's not every director has a brave
the guts to go to direct in this way no
how epic something can be you know cuz
it's like well I'm just going for a
close-up and and then in manipulates it
like this so it's just a different kind
of directing that I don't think a lot of
people can do or even a studio would
give them the ability to go here's
hundreds of millions of dollars I want
you to do this story that everyone knows
or something and make something grand
happen you know that doesn't happen
yeah well he's proven it's also made
totally yeah totally so um you were born
with this very very young sounding voice
and this is transition into voice acting
work right and you've done everything
from young men the teenagers to young
boys uh is it a strange transition you
seem to pick it up pretty easily I don't
even know you know it's uh I don't you
know you don't really hear your own
voice when you talk I don't think so I'm
always concern uh it's best you doing
voice acting yeah I don't know how my
voice this is I don't know so like
someone asked me on tell us
about their just saying you sound the
same
you know like hook that's like all of a
sudden they're watching hook and they
hear it Prince Zuko right the whole time
and I go is it possible that my voice
hasn't changed since I was 15
is that even remotely possible and like
fans watch yes
it is what I'm like I don't know how
that sounds crazy I don't know I don't
know how that happens I really don't
really focus a lot on the voice I mean
if it's maybe young a character I'll
think younger to certain degree but uh
I'm just trying to act and whether
there's a camera in the room or a
microphone in the room I'm just I'm just
trying to act you know is there any
point where you have to say a line or a
phrase where you're like really that's
what the kids are saying okay or a line
you don't understand it's just sort of
ah I mean certain things like wood with
a wooden we did Jake along the American
dragon we improved a lot of those lines
me and the other actress Kitty and but
you know it's like a hip-hop kind of
show and I'm like very much of the
hip-hop generation so I was probably
using slang like that was from art my
from my generation more than their
generation the kids at that time but we
had a good time doing that stuff now you
know I tries to take the script as much
as possible um when you played Zuko on
Avatar just tell me about that whole
experience because that character and
that showed to me is amazing I don't
even know where to begin with it
just tell me about that whole experience
about the fan just everything connected
to that show what's your take on well
the beginning of it is uh
they call me into um it's a Nickelodeon
to go meet these producers for the show
right they could give you the script and
the character it's like Zuko and of
course my first thought is Zuko is Danny
Zuko and you know very similar yeah I
was like I like Danny is it good so
funny and they're like laughing when I
met Mike and Bryan the first time and
I'm reading through the script and I'm
like this is obviously some epic Asian
and inspired martial arts a series for
Nickelodeon and in my mind I really
didn't even think it was gonna go I was
like this is not
I I it's I think everyone still maids a
Nickelodeon enjoy because they haven't
done any air shows like that
of course when you walk in there when I
walked into Nickelodeon that day I
literally was reading this Asian spire
situation and you're looking at statues
of Spongebob Squarepants and big
portraits of cat dog memory cat go yeah
so cat dog and like the buildings all
white at that time it has like Grand
Slam on top I mean it's Nickelodeon and
I'm like this isn't Nickelodeon this is
something else
this is my Nickelodeon um and I just
thought you know face style you I
thought should be the bad guy on the
show and I was like all right cool I'm
the bad guy who's chasing the the good
guy around all right
and we did that pilot episode and it
kind of got picked up on start running
and I really think much about it
the first kind of season of it I just
thought I was a bad guy cool
I didn't see some of the artwork um
during the second season when it started
well I don't know how it breaks down
as far as when it's coming up in the
second season we start seeing the
character being more you know yeast
though after the steam of the father we
get scarred and I start east I just
really see the character progression in
a character arc of the story start I
start like really kind of falling in
love like oh my god what's going on like
this is crazy this guy is even more than
what I expected or what anyone expected
and me and the other cast Jack's Anna
Mae Whitman we'd come in like did you
read what happened this week in the
script like that kind of stuff started
happening for us as we were doing it so
I didn't know even how big it was until
it was going on I was doing the movie
take the lead Toronto when tone even
Downers we're like and I'm leaving the
set every week to uh to shoot episodes
the core episodes while I was in Toronto
and I remember one time I'm leaving the
set and one of the actors brand Andrew
seems like the bigger guy in the movie
and he's like where are you going I'm
like um doing a cartoon I gotta run out
and do a cartoon for a few hours because
a cartoon with cartoon what do you we
doing and he's I'm like oh it's the show
for Nickelodeon called avatar last
airbender and he was like flipped out
he's like what well that's that's my
show and I like
seeing it through his eyes in that
moment is when I first started seeing
the the popularity of the show and then
from there you know just the whole art
by the time I've finished then we start
really seeing how popular the show got
and what's weird is we weren't we
weren't connected as a because it's
before like Twitter kind of blew up and
I don't even think being Facebook's at
that time so we didn't really understand
how popular the show got later on when I
did Korra where everyone's connected we
know how pop of that show is and how
fast core is going to grow so it's been
an amazing amazing journey in that way
you come into this part yet you play a
teenager but you play it as so on as
pretty much probably double as age do
you feel it gives you an advantage on
the character knowing more what this
character is going through seeing how
you may have gone through it before I
could see that um I mean yeah of course
there's a there's that there's a there's
a lot of these scenes that that Zuko has
played with this plane with his father
and his uncle that I've got to play
those scenes in real life a because I've
been through that age and also I've got
to play those scenes in other television
and films um every actor they say has a
certain casting that's their sweet spot
you know the actors that work a long
time whether they be stars or whatever
they usually play the same characters
over and over again that's like the kind
of the big trick in Hollywood that a lot
of people a lot of times you don't
really understand if you watch a
Harrison Ford film if you watch a chum
cruise come they're actually playing the
same characters before it's over and
over and over again unlike Jeff Goldblum
who has just been so new yeah like it's
amazing where straight looking it's like
he just become somebody else every time
right which there's they said Oh sir
someone's home is the way acting works
is a year they gonna play characters
closer to yourself or you can play
characters further than yourself right
like the character actor the leading man
actor Lee Dominican are going to play
curtains close to their self but what's
runs hotter or not we we we seem to
think that sometimes it's harder to play
character outside of yourself with me
but first character actors might be hard
for them to play a character that's more
like themselves
now but but the character I play seems
like over and over my career at least
growing up was always the kid that was
the bad kid turned good and has a heart
of gold in the end and somehow is able
to redeem himself and so for many films
I play this character a lot and like in
a lot of ways Rufio and Prince Zuko are
the same character and so yeah so you're
able to play these scenes again and
again and maybe fine-tune them I don't
know
that wasn't the director wrote me a note
when I did this film take the lead with
Antonio and I did and on the same kind
of character was like this badass kid
who actually becomes very cool kids at
the end and she's like you did some
things in the film that made Antonio
Banderas changes his performance a few
times right I'm like oh that's cool that
I was like thank you for the compliment
but then the same time I mind like I
played this character somebody if I
don't lay this character by now you know
then I don't know what I'm doing oh
we're talking about avatar franchise
gotta ask the question yeah you seen the
movie know how impossible I just didn't
I never saw it uh you know Mike and
Bryan told me how to see it they're like
don't make him out about it they said
they they weren't happy when they
finally came out yeah they said they
weren't happy they're like don't watch
it man it's not you know what there's
nothing there's nothing I don't even
think it's M night Shyamalan I'm
actually a fan of especially the early
films Sixth Sense is amazing film I
think I'm broken is my favorite film is
uh I'm break I'm breakable I'm sorry
I'm a regular find my favorite oh
because I love that twist on the
superhero film uh that's actually I want
a few people that I think we share that
because I actually do like that I like
them like a lot of people don't like it
yeah I I can see why but like I
I'm one of you that likes the ending as
well like how you like yeah I liked it
it was it's a superhero film that is not
as very unsupervised and I just think
it's a you know it's a misstep who knows
I it's like if I ever audition for him
nice I got he's like I read I saw
something online where he said some bad
it's just hard to make a film honestly
it's hard if it was easy to make a
brilliant film uh we'd be making more
brilliant films as a community you know
but it's hard I just think it's a
there's probably some things they say I
keep talking to talk about could I never
saw the film um I just wish you know I
wish you'd kind of did better in that
sense did you see it
oh I think it's like my second most
watched review really yeah and and ooh
what's it just that bad it's not bad but
you know it's it's bad but at the same
time it's in my opinion it's dead on
arrival because you can't do a movie on
the first season you can't do it and
satisfy anybody in my opinion so it's
not so but would've been good if you
didn't know the series uh it wouldn't
attitude in that no but from what I've
heard there's other thing like you said
you're saying it it you don't know if
it's entirely Sean Wilentz problem and
also that every film I would say every
film is kind of like a little miracle
could I are so terrible and it's so much
going into it uh and hearing some of the
stories going into the bout why they had
to make certain casting choices right
and what some of the decisions you know
I don't entirely blame Shyamalan but
it's a it's a tough project to try and
do anyway and it's kind of it was kind
of destined it's pretty hard I think you
know I wish they believed Mike and Brian
sand put more because those guys hold
the Bible to the story
you know um and my biggest nut qualms
with them but the thing I wrote I wrote
a blog when it was coming out because
some of you were asking me questions I
finalized like a 2:00 a.m. the morning
wrote something and then why the time to
write so II wasn't the best time to
write it because I actually got freaked
out the next morning when it kind of
went viral and then all of a sudden like
Nickelodeon's calling me up what are you
writing about Mike ah I just I just I
don't know to it but my whole thing was
basically and you know Mike and Brian
agreed me well it's just on the casting
right so not even about a me playing
Prince Zuko which would have been great
um and I'm actually a fan of Dev Patel
so and I sure did a fine job he's a fine
actor but just up with the and character
being ethnic actor in LA and growing up
in
getting my career launched by being a
movie like hook right there's not a lot
of roles for say like a young Asian
actor um and the fact that you weren't
able to cast one in this particular film
was a missed opportunity for launching
someone's career and nothing gets a kid
who played Aang it's just that there's
other roles for Caucasian kids that come
out a lot you know more often than
something this kind of big to really
kind of shed light on maybe give give
the chance for a new kid to kind of a
springboard for his career we don't know
if it could have been the next you know
the first Asian Will Smith for Holly
where something like that and I just
thought it was a missed opportunity
because I know the power of what the
holiday is if you can kind of give a
young kid a shot in that way and there's
not going to be there's not a lot of
chances for young Asian rolls like that
but let's be honest the film did so
poorly
maybe yeah obably saved right way right
right right
you know maybe they phos gonna try out
and anyone did something else and that
was a big hit or so we don't know that
either I just wrote that during the time
so that just I just came up from that
point of view you know but uh yeah so
weird they're like well we didn't want
to cast this but we want we want to
pronounce the names correctly but that
was the big that was the first telltale
sign for me they can't get the names are
like well it's not a it's all and we're
like what it's like doing where we do
you know Star Wars to be like no it's
local Skywalker how does that work if
there was a Loki Skywalker if that's in
the news I'll go to it would be amazing
okay Scotty Juan Castillo has like the
big win today yeah yeah the long blonde
hair turns into the horns let's make the
second eco
Abrams just watching I'm excited I'm a
I'm a fan of always been a big fan of
Star Wars so I'm excited too for the new
trilogy to come out ya know it should be
fun I'm curious see what they're gonna
do I'm curious do
Daunte how old are you 39 where is this
unicorn blood you are drinking to keep
this youthful one and where can we get
it by God you still look like you're 22
or something I don't know it's got to be
all that time I spent in Neverland they
had to be that for sure I don't know
what it is I guess it's La very I think
everyone kind of and la is like a
Neverland place so people kind of slow
down an age over there no seasons no
seasons those is the endless temperate
summer kind of thing
oh and lucky I took a walk just luck I
always tell people it's gonna amateur
overnight and we'll go from The Karate
Kid to mr. Miyagi like overnight
I gotta turn around all of a sudden like
the old wise man will see when that day
comes um you are known for acting
obviously for screen acting and voice
acting but I think that's what most
people serve connect you to but you do a
million other things you're a producer
you're a writer you do poetry you put
productions yeah you do all sorts of
what is a typical week like for you um
yeah it's pretty it's crazier than I
think and I forget I actually flogged
for my first time like a month straight
like every day anyway I was pretty
amazed about how much crazy stuff that I
do myself um so it's wild you know I
started a poetry venue about 1718 years
ago in Los Angeles and it became the
largest of mic bang in the country so
I've been very involved in the spoken
word poetry scene for the last two
decades so that's always going on I have
a prescient company in Hawaii called
kinetic films it does Asian American
Pacific Islander films and we produce
three times so far i co-wrote the fourth
film that we're getting funding for
right now and so we're doing in the
midst of that and I wrote a play called
me and I make out session that were that
had a few really good runs that were
going to do a new run of it soon I
started a collective downtown called we
own the 8th which is an asian-american
arts collective about collaborating
YouTube artists digital artists with
traditional media folks and really
trying to create an asian-american genre
and America
as far as media and the whole concert we
came up with this we on the 8th which is
co-opting the 8th in the month for new
media new Asian media every month so we
released new media every month and kind
of promote for each other so I it's kind
of I've been around LA a long time in
the industry and part of being in
Hollywood sticking around so long as
keeping yourself creatively active and
busy we can always what kills me is just
kind of sitting around waiting for
auditions which is always it's like
that's part of life in LA I mean we're
constantly auditioning whether it be on
screen voice stuff commercial anything
everything that's just how the town
works but I didn't round so long that
you also wanna your ear your tool and
other people's story as an actor becomes
a time we go when you're like a few
stories that I want to help tell to
whether it be a story that I write or
whether it's a story that I find from
someone else and let's get together and
create that and there's no better time
than now digitally where we can you know
we all have cameras all my friends we
all have cameras we all have Heights we
have time and let's shoot stuff and
let's collaborate and so it's really
really kind of vibrant time in LA right
now it's really exciting you've worked
with as I said before a lot of screen
legends a lot of huge huge names uh
which one or ones have left the biggest
impact on you um I mean of course the
hook days those guys are all those I
mean Spielberg Hoffman Williams they're
super big just because it's my teenage
days and my kind of really big entrance
into Hollywood you know um and Antonio
Banderas always it's great you know the
big stars you you work with you kind of
start to understand why they're stars
when you talk to them and when you
interact with them they definitely make
you feel like special just weird thing
it's kind of like we're talking to
Antonio's telling somebody you know you
you know especially that's how I always
say I'm pretty hip kind of guy and think
I got it going on then you meet someone
like that walks in room like who's that
guy right
and then he's talking to you and like
everyone else disappears in the room
and he's telling whatever you tell you
anything I don't know he's talking about
he leaves a room he does the big ZZ yeah
you're looking at this guy this guy has
really pretty eyes
sorry if the George Clooney effect yeah
it was sucky exactly uh it's so neat
every film has its own thing you know
and has its own employees its own impact
on you it's it's it's kind of
interesting I tell folks a lot of
audience watch films would be done
whether they big bigger films or
independent films or whatnot and and
their experiences doing audience things
so that's very impactful but when I look
at the films most time it's really like
looking at a photo album of my life
right so I'm watching hook are from
watching but I'm a cheerleader I'm
looking at like oh my god I gotta call
that person God remember like that time
when we were on that set it's like
looking at that even looking at hook
you're going got caught June Mariu up he
just had a kid I gotta go hang out him
or rashon and play thug but like I
didn't mean to see one of his magic
shows I had to turn out your movies are
kind of like everyone else's Facebook
like oh yeah I got you yeah yeah I got
it's like your Facebook exactly so um so
when you're been around town as long as
I have which is coming up on 30 years
almost you you have a lot of different
you know photo albums of people that you
need to every time it comes up people
you need to kind of reconnect with um we
lost a great town yes here a lot of us
didn't know him personally but let the
big impact on us regardless and you have
worked with them right course what are
your memories of rebel limbs um you know
a that he was a very caring and gentle
kind of man it was amazing I mean I'll
forever be I've been talking in a few
years um but I'll forever be connected
to him because of rufio and Peter Pan
and that kind of relationship and my my
first memory is that everything that you
wanted that you want Rob Williams to be
when you meet him he delivers in spades
right he's the one thing he taught me at
that age was that one year that when
you're the lead in the film when you're
when you're like the number one on the
call sheet meaning like you're the star
of the film you're responsible somewhat
for the morale of the whole set crew
cast and everything and he took that
whole cast crew on his shoulders for
months long days we people don't realize
how hard it is to make movies you know
it's fun to watch but you understand
that we're working for 14 16 hour days
and there's drama and there's madness
and if you if someone goes into a bad
mood or someone's being a diva it could
really spin the whole morale of the set
like people don't want to work for
people that are jerks you know and he's
on the set cracking jokes and making
sure everyone's having a good time and
laughing all day long and that was
beautiful to see and to work with him in
really the expertise of him as a
brilliant quick-witted just master you
he felt that every day every scene um
and then on the other side you know we
talked about poetry
I mean def post-assad it was a really
big film for me in my life and why I
became a poet and so we would spend a
lot of mornings just talking about all
the transcendental poets that he loved
from that movie like Thoreau but also we
talked about Charles Bukowski he's one
of my favorite poets I would talk about
by anything like in different poetry he
would to give me all these ideas and so
I really got to be spent talent on that
soft-spoken side and uh and then you
know just him as a person like when I
first met him one of the things he was
like what are you he's like what's your
background and I'm like oh I'm Filipino
he's like my wife my wife's a Filipino
and he's really welcoming me welcoming
you into this world the thing about it
is it as an actor or as anyone coming
into Hollywood a lot of times we feel
we're on the outside looking in you know
you're like this is a big party that I'm
not invited to even if you get invited
the party you just feel like am I
supposed to be at this party you know
I'm saying the the invitation go to the
wrong person and and for someone like a
big star to kind of welcome you in and
then find places to like like little
thing like that meant so much to me like
you know you're part of this too
is not outside of you the you're part of
this thing is a really lovely thing to
do really a beautiful thing to do that
that you don't need to do and it's very
cool
so like doesn't my memories and my
feelings of a man for years he he was
always sent me Christmas cards and so I
just have beautiful memories of them
like that
a lot of people don't know this but you
have worked with Fred Savage twice once
on Wonder Years which people have seen
yes and once on the wizard right but
they can't see you in the woods they
can't see me cuz there are you hiding I
got cut out of that movie
a lot of people don't realize but a lot
of actors do a lot of different things
that you may get cut out of and the
wizard was one of them I black you
played been savages but I mean Fred
savages best friend in the film from his
home town and they go we did all the
shooting over the summer and then end up
in at the final a final championship
game and I have like so many crazy
memories with Fred and the whole Savage
family and Ben and all them hanging out
for the summer in Jenny Lewis when we
were kids running around Rina we shot
and we shot and we're living in the
Bally's casino in Reno so I have like a
lot of memories of just being a kid
running around there bowling
staying up all night it's weird when
you're a kid in a casino cuz you kind of
you know you're safe to go around the
casino you know and your per diem so but
we end up getting cut out of that Phil I
end up getting cut out me and the other
guys that played his best friends but
it's so weird because uh a I remember
running into Ben savage years ago at a
club and he tasked me on the shoulder
he's like do you remember me like my
Fred's little brother I'm like yeah dude
bet I know you what's going on uh any
we're talking about the wizard and just
that was just a funnest time it's great
to be a young actor in these films you
do you just have these like little uh
you know friendships that go on we're
not biggest memories from that is
watching there's a whole MTV show me and
Fred were watching with the other kids I
think was remote control and yeah yeah
and we had like the biggest crush on car
I were some reason awesome she's hot and
then I remember singing Bobby Brown
every little step' would like would Fred
Savage and we're dancing around like
funny things like that people have their
memories
of like junior high or like elementary
school and and I do too and a lot of my
memories just happened to be with kids
like Fred Savage or something like that
because those are years I was in junior
high or elementary school so so is
flying shots Fred you know sandwich
family well he hasn't gone on to
anything just directing every direction
every old LP episode and yeah he was
always brilliant even back then he was
like smarter than everybody else he
seemed like a little mutant alien
prodigy like he talked like he was
thirty years old it was ugly like no kid
talked like how he talked in the movie
just seemed like beyond anyone any kid
that age in terms of intelligence he was
he was definitely just a lot of the
young actors were really brilliant kids
Charlie Korres Moe who was in hook was
brilliant brilliant kid like super smart
um you run to all these kids I mean
Mayan Mayim Bialik when she was on a
she's brilliant she was on blossom and
we did the Earth Day special together
she was brilliant
she I saw her recently before she got a
Big Bang Theory and she was like doing
brain surgery or something at UCLA
actual brains yeah I'm like you're
actually abroad actually like a brain
doctors like a neurosurgeon that's what
she said I'm like what my what are you
talking about
like I just been acting this whole time
she was laughing so there's like a lot I
mean you know there's a lot of children
actors that become drug addicts and kind
of mess up but there's a lot of us that
actually were smart kids that kind of
went on to rocket science or brain
surgery because it you as you said so
many child stars have gone to this dark
place and haven't gotten out kind of
understandably so it's a weird
environment yeah and you're thrown into
something where it's hard to have a
normal childhood you see them come out
of it okay well why do you think that is
what do you think was the secret again
yeah I think it's good family all my
brothers and sisters are actors and
artists and still in industry and so it
just becomes less of a of a magical
thing and more like this is kind of what
we do but I've you know I've seen a lot
of been around a long time
time so I've seen friends I see a lot of
times leave the town I've seen some
friends die would it be through drugs or
just through the mishaps of life and and
and that kind of lifestyle so I just you
know you just I think it's really being
around good family and now I'm seeing
the next generation my brother his kids
are acting and they're doing well
my other brother his like stepson is
coming out a bunch of films and he's
about to kind of take off and he's come
out with new film with Bill Murray and
seeing it happening again the next
generation is kind of like a beautiful
kind of thing um but at the same token
like you said like my family's like a
really good family to be around acting
family so I just hope that everyone kind
of keeps your feet on the ground and
understands like this way it is and I
think the kids they their feet are on
the ground pretty well because they see
us you know acting all the time we're
all like doing commercials or films and
they're visiting the sets and then if
they're around the country shootings
like one of us are around they're also
like oh I'm here doing this so it just
feels like not not that's not a big deal
you know I'm saying it's like this is
what we do we're an entertainment family
and writing producing directing that's
what we do music that's what we do and
it's not anything out of the ordinary
whether what kind of success you get is
is is a you know hopefully you're
fortunate to have bigger success but
it's not like it's like not like wow aw
it's not like an O in it it's just what
we do but then every interview with two
polar opposite question okay the first
one being whether it be professional or
personal what is the toughest thing
you've ever had to go through and how
did you get through it ah God the
toughest thing was um yeah you know like
I said everyone has their everyone in
Hollywood has wrote their e true
Hollywood story it especially been
around any period of time everyone does
and so of course I me my family do so we
had a really dark kind of period where
like we didn't talk for like seven years
which is crazy because we're a very
tight family
but that that had to do with a lot of
factors in town that I had to deal with
loud acting in business so getting
through that was pretty harsh but what
you know I think ironically getting
through it is getting back to family
which is great you know yeah it's just
weird and it's kind of vague but part of
it is it's just it's just Hollywood I
mean a lot of things in Hollywood
happening there's things that happen
especially as kid actors and ultimately
people have to kind of like watch out
for as far as who you put your trust in
who you end up falling you know and
there's a lot of different relationships
whether they be acting teachers managers
you know and these things can get
convoluted and that can also disrupt
family life also so just kind of get
back to family and get back to what what
home is yeah I find that way
and finally again whether professional
or personally what is the proudest thing
you've ever done um you know recently it
was I produced a docu-series where I
brought my family home to the
Philippines and it's like this really
big kind of thing where for me is this
ideas like really an American story
where nation immigrants and then just go
back to where you're from whether it be
Asia where it be whether it be Africa or
Latin America or Europe and you kind of
really find out you know as Americans we
always go where are we really from them
and outside of Americans were off from
somewhere else so I brought my whole
family back all my four brothers my
sister my parents and as artists we went
back to see where we're from and it's so
weird because my grandfather is from a
really small village in the Philippines
right rice fields oh that's what we
ended up still there we went his little
sister he's passed away but his little
sister who's now in her late 80s still
lives there in a hut and on these rice
smells that we had for hundreds of years
and to bring my family back
and for us to go there and realize that
in two generations time for my
grandfather go from this village to us
making movies in Hollywood would be the
equivalent of my grandchild
walking on the moon or something like
that that's how far the distance is you
know both economically and physically
and just mentally it's proud I'm proud
to go wow this is what we've done and
what we've done with the family and just
see where we're going I'm like very
proud of my family at this point of my
life so very very happy in that with
that sense wonderful this has been Dante
Bosco on shut up and talk thank you and
take care now this is where we would
catch are we talking yes oh yeah no
we're just gonna say stuff it's like but
now we're gonna laugh but that's
seriously what what unicorn to use like
the blood I know is I so insanely
jealous I don't know I'm telling you I'm
going to trying to miss meal you know
that all of a sudden so nice gonna turn
into this I don't believe it I just
can't keep getting younger and younger
would you do I will be there this deal
and I was telling someone we gotta do a
movie but uh I can do movie Ralph
Macchio cuz he still looks great and
then we'll see that's another one who
never ate you must you'll never ages